Hello everybody!
Change of stream plans.
I play... I play karaoke!
I play karaoke!
Fun time!
Fun time, fun time!
First stream of the day and I'm early!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for 18 months!
Change first stream today, no?
Yes!
Really looking forward to karaokeing it up.
It's been a while since I last karaokeed it up.
May the 4th be with a boo!
Oh, it is May the 4th.
Minto karaoke, I'm a birthday, love me, Minto!
Hi Sumi!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Shall we sing a happy birthday song?
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you Happy birthday
dear Hi Sumi Happy birthday to you Oh, hey, oh, happy
birthday!
Oh, my week has also been, pardon my French, duty!
Help me through it, this world sucks, but people like,
you've managed to shine right through the endless dark.
Wee!
I hope to that, I hope, well, it's only, it's Monday.
It's Tuesday?
It's Monday?
It's Monday!
No, Jake.
I hope that the rest of your week is good.
I hope so.
So...
It's a Monday!
I thought it was Tuesday.
Oh, Mondays.
Hello, Mito, my wife.
Congrats on the concert.
Thank you, Kato!
I love Mito karaoke.
Yippee!
I'm glad!
We're just gonna vibe?
Mito, thank you!
it is a tuesday in japan so true happy tuesday nice to have
meet and greet you oh thank you yeah thanks for coming to
see us your eye your uh what was it um i remember i when we
when oh my gosh i'm getting all tongue-tied when you came in
um phoebe and vicky had never seen that I blue shirt before
like the Hawaiian one and so they were like oh my gosh the
shirt is so good and I was like right and we were like you
wear it so well me though my wife thanks for the Monday
starter what does yeah let's get rid of some Monday blues
maybe it's Monday and those suck Mondays suck so let's let's
sing some songs to get rid of monday blues
so true thanks for saying yes to snake at ocea fling
definitely did not send this message before today
no you didn't thank you missed my ears it was amazing to
meet you and denzil so i wish you up like this weekend the
concert was amazing packed and so energetic y'all are angels
and i'm happy to see you succeed enjoy the bioshark book
yeah oh i want to see it i really want to see it thank you
so much for coming to see us yeah
i want to do more mean greets thank you so much for that
warning i did thank you So cute!
Let's see.
Yeah, the concert was so much fun.
I was trying not to laugh during...
There was a group.
So, like, you know, there's feedback on the...
What's it called?
The...
Like, me watching you guys, right?
But there was, like, a particular group of people that were
so close to the mic.
Like...
I hear them so much.
And like they're mixing, like their calls and everything.
It was making me crack up.
I was like, oh my gosh, I can't.
It was so funny.
Still alive was hilarious.
When everyone started going, Oh, they're mo!
Oh my gosh.
I was listening to karaoke.
Blue skies someday maybe in the future.
Yes, I have to learn it first though.
It might be a little bit before.
Congrats on the concert over the weekend.
Guest announcement today, Minto.
Question mark, what day?
Couldn't make Oshia blink, but looking forward to Offka.
Yes, Offka will be so hype.
So, so hype.
You helped me get rid of my life, Blues.
Last week, I defended my PhD thesis.
I've been watching your streams while I worked on
everything.
Thank you for everything.
Whoa!
PhDs.
Smart IB.
What are you thinking for music tonight?
Anything goes.
Whatever I feel like.
Yeah.
Sabrina Carpenter.
Okay, or I'll sing Sabrina Carpenter for you.
Which one though?
I'm looking at, like, I'm on Carafone, I'm looking at the
top global songs of all time.
Let's see, what's a, let's, oh wait, top of, what's a viral
US?
Oh, oh, are these, oh, interesting.
Oh.
Forever Meow!
I'm late, but I'm so happy you like...
Yeah!
Yes, the Hawaiian shirts!
They're so great!
Thank you!
Puddle of mud!
Wait.
Of mud.
Puddle of mud.
Do I even know how this song goes?
Wait, what's the song?
Which one is it?
What about the yata song?
song.
Blurry!
Okay, I will sing a blurry.
Ace Combat song real quick.
Glad I got the meet and greet with you this weekend.
The concert was phenomenal in celebration of May the 4th.
Do you think you could acapella duel of the fates?
What is that?
I don't even know what duel of the fates is.
I don't know any Star Wars!
It's from Star Wars.
The lightsaber fight song.
Okay, hold on.
I'll do our acapella it right now.
I'm scared to say this, but I like Steiner a little bit.
It's an act, I swear to you.
It's an act!
He puts on a show!
No!
You can't do that!
You have to be on my side!
I made a Zoid's AMV with this song Blurry 17 years ago?
Shut up.
No way.
Okay, here's me.
My impression of of lightsaber fight song Acapella.
Tuck it up.
Light saber boom Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum
Bum
Sorry, hold on I just knocked something over Bum Bum Bum Bum
Bum Bum Bum And then they fight.
.
Why is it dubstep?
I don't know.
.
How is
that?
How is that?
Where are we in the song?
Obi and Wan Kenobi just died!
Oh, no!
Oh, wait.
Sad, sad, sad now.
Oh, I started the Metal Gear.
Wait, does Obi Wan Kenobi die?
Wait, what do you mean, spoilers?
Wait, does he actually?
mean to spoil it i've never seen the movie wait does
obi-walk and obi-die die oh my gosh i'm so sorry i just
snake double door dude uh-oh happy monday meeto you have a
job you're on job good luck with your work scuba scuba gator
good luck with work got the rough and thank you for the pick
dang i thought you never watched star wars but i stand
corrected you know your stuff It's going in the playlist.
No, but thank you so much for the fifth to get in.
Not in the movie you're currently referencing.
Oh!
Wait, which one am I referencing?
You just spoiled the thing that happened in the 70s.
I wonder if Jedi's used their lightsabers as light sticks.
They just accidentally murder people and chop off arms
sometimes.
Yeah.
I've heard of that guy before.
If you need a song to celebrate May 4th, there's always a
Galactic Empire state of mind, which is a parody.
Holy ho, ho, ho, ho.
Obligatory.
Star Wars watch a long win.
Sometime?
Right again.
Welcome back, Dink.
Bip.
Okay, I'm going to sing a blurry.
I don't know how this song goes.
I think I remember.
This is a warm-up.
This is a warm-up song.
It's so blurry.
Everyone's... I don't know how it goes.
Everybody's empty.
Everything's so so messed up.
Preoccupy without you.
I cannot live at all.
My whole world surrounds you.
I stumble and I crawl.
You could be my son.
You could be my scene You know that I'll protect you From
all of the obscene I wonder what you're doing Imagine where
you are There's oceans in between us But that's not very far
Can you take it all away?
When you shoved it in my face, this pain you gave to me, can
you take it all away?
When you shoved it in my face.
Okay, I think I'm good.
Okay, that was a good warm up.
My throat feels thoroughly lubricated and then ready to
sing.
normal luna happy birthday oh you're doing a karaoke chintan
as i wait for my flight home it's been delayed five times oh
my gosh also i love your snoopy i love snoopy i love snoopy
snoopy i love snoopy i love snoopy i love snoopy can you
dang it out of the way It's Snoopy.
It's Snoopy.
Totally threw that as a joke, but thank you.
That made my day.
I'm really glad.
We'll do an equally...
Let's see.
Equally, like, kind of vibe.
Oh.
Try this one.
All the small things True care truth brings I'll take one
lift Your ride, best trip Always I know you'll be at my show
Watching Waiting Commiserating Say it ain't so, I will not
go Turn the lights off, carry me home Nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah
Homework sucks, I know She left me roses by the stairs
Surprises let me know she cares Say it ain't so, I will not
go Turn the lights off, carry me home Nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah
Say it ain't so, I will not go Turn the lights off, carry me
home Keep your head still, I'll be your thrill The night
will go on, my little windmill Say it ain't so, I will not
go Turn the lights off, carry me home Keep your head still,
I'll be your thrill The night will go on, the night will go
on, My little windmill Yay!
Nia, nia, nia, nia, nia, nia, nia, nia, nia, nia, nia, nia,
nia, nia, nia, nia, nia, nia, nia, nia, nia.
Yay!
Suddenly cat, always cat.
Always cat.
Nickelback?
Any song.
Okay.
Nickelback.
Hmm.
Hmm, any song?
I think I...
I'm like, how much...
Besides, like, photograph, what other nickelback do I know?
Nibikor, thank you for the five gift.
Thank you.
Oh!
Nibi, thank you for writing!
Kumbakua!
Well, you were playing The Force again, right?
Kapoteku!
With, uh, Limu.
Distinguished with Seriq.
Ito!
Demi!
Animals.
Do I know this one?
Isn't this a freaky song?
Wait,
I actually don't know it.
Why is it freaky?
I have a heart or...
I was polite if the devil needs a ride Because my angel and
my right ain't hanging out with me tonight I'm driving past
your house Well, you were sneaking out I got the corridor
open up So you can jump in on the run Your mom don't know
You were missing, you'd be pissed if you could see that part
of you That I've been kissing, screaming But now I'm gonna
quit Ain't nothing wrong with it Just acting like we're
animals Cause everybody knows We're just a couple animals
Animals!
Oh my goodness.
My goodness.
I know what I want to sing though, because Nimi rated.
This song.
I have a heart, I swear I do, but just not, baby, when it
comes to you, I get so hungry.
When you say you love me, hush if you know what's good for
you.
I think you're hot, I think you're cool.
You're the kind of guy I'd suck.
in school now that i'm famous you're with my anus now i'm
gonna i'm gonna eat you full i eat boys up breakfast and
lunch then when i'm thirsty i drink their blood carnivore
animal i am a cannibal i eat boys up you'd better run i am
cannibal i am I am cannibal I'll eat you up I am cannibal I
am cannibal I'll eat you up Whenever you tell me, I'm pretty
That's when the hunger really hits me Your little heart goes
pitter-patter I want your liver on a platter You use your
finger to steer my teeth Then for desire, I'll suck your
teeth be sweet and you'll be a goner yep i pull a jeffrey
domer i eat boys up breakfast and lunch then when i'm
thirsty i drink their blood carnival animal i am a cannibal
i eat boys up you'd better run
I am a cannibal I
am a cannibal I
am a cannibal I'll
eat you up I am a cannibal
I warned you
Yeah, yeah, she drank too much blood.
Delicious.
Yippee!
I'm like going through the top 90s songs.
Top 90s.
There's so many, though.
oh oh oh wait i forgot to write that one down cannibal i all
i am i am cannibal
hold on wait what's this one how this one go again hold on i
feel like i saw this one oh yeah this one's good this one's
good i like this song too yeah barbie girl sorry let me
start writing some down barbie girl that one's fun ariana
grande i like ariana grande
i'm just picking whatever i feel like guys there's really no
rhyme or reason to anything it's just kind of how i feel
up or ever to touch you because I know that you feel me
somehow you're the closest to heaven that I'll ever be and I
don't want to go home right now Oh, Acapella!
Oh my god!
Ah!
Oops, that's so awkward, sorry.
Now I'm embarrassed.
Now I'm embarrassed!
Now I don't I don't want to sing anymore.
I'm embarrassed.
Sing it?
Okay, I'll try it again.
What did you guys do when I was just sitting here in
darkness?
I mean, not darkness, it's silence then.
in darkness and I give up forever to touch you because I
know that you'd feel me somehow you're the closest to heaven
that I'll ever be and I don't want to go home right now and
all I can taste the darkness and all I can breathe is your
life cuz sooner or later it's over I just don't want to miss
you tonight and I don't want the world to see me cuz I don't
think that they'd understand When everything's meant to be
broken, I just want you to know who I am.
And you can't part the tears that ain't coming, or the
moment of truth in your lies.
When everything feels like the movies, yeah you bleed just
to know you're alive.
I don't want the world to see me Cause I don't think that
they'd understand When everything's made to be broken I just
want you to know who I am Fongest instrumental ever I
don't want sushi or sashimi
Oh yeah, that was my sick solo.
And I don't want the world to see me Because I don't think
that they'd understand When everything's made to be broken I
just want you to know who I am And I don't want the world to
see me see me because I don't think that they'd understand
when everything's made to be broken I just want you to know
who I am I just want you to know who I am I just want you to
know who I am I just want you to know who I am Believe it or
not, she did that whole instrumental piece herself I know
That's who I am That's who I am That's me Wait I know some
people really like this song so i'm gonna sing this one too
simple and clean oh my gosh okay i can add it to the list
can i hit those can i hit those notes actually we'll see if
i can hit those notes in a second
let's see let's see let's see oh maybe let's try it
i know people really like this when i sing this song, but I
also just really like this song.
I was the one who had it all.
I was the master of my fate.
I never needed anybody in my life.
I learned the truth too late.
I'll never shake away the pain.
I close my eyes but she's still there I let her steal into
my melancholy heart It's more than I can bear Now I know
she'll never leave me Even as she runs away She will still
torment me me, hurt me, move me, come what may.
Wasting in my lonely tower, waiting by an open door.
Huffle myself, she'll walk right in, and be with me
forevermore.
I curse the fading of the light.
Though she's already flown so far beyond my reach, she's
never out of sight.
Now I know she'll never leave me, even as she faints from
you.
She will still inspire me.
Be a part of everything I do Wasting in my lonely tower
Waiting by an open door I fool myself shall walk right in
And as the long, long nights begin I'll think of all that
might have been
here forever more
simple and clean huh maybe we can if I can hit I've been
recording a lot today if I can't hit the high notes don't
yell at me okay
yeah yeah yeah I want to sing more Disney song I mean This
is kind of Disney song.
When you walk away, you don't hear me say, Please, oh, baby,
don't go.
Simple and clean is the way that you're making me feel
tonight.
It's hard to let it go.
for giving me too many things lately you're all I need oh
you smiled at me and said don't get me wrong I love you but
does that mean I have to meet your father when we are You'll
understand what I meant when I said no.
I don't think life is quite that simple.
When you walk away, you don't hear me say, Please, oh baby,
don't go.
Simple and clean is the way that you're making me feel.
night it's hard to let it go so simple and clean the daily
things like this and that and what is what that keep us all
busy are confusing me that's when you And said, wish I could
prove I love you, but does that mean I have to walk on
water?
When we are older, you'll understand it's enough when I say
so.
And maybe some things are that simple.
When you walk away, you don't hear me say, please.
So baby, don't go simple and clean It's the way that you're
making me feel tonight It's hard to let it go Hold me,
whatever lies me on this morning Is a little later on
Regardless of warnings, the future doesn't matter scare me
at all nothing's like before when you walk away you don't
hear me say please oh baby don't go simple and clean is the
way that you're making me feel tonight it's hard to let it
go me whatever lies beyond this morning is a little later on
regardless of warnings the future doesn't scare me at all
nothing's like me for hold me whatever lies me on this
morning is a little later on Regardless of warnings, the
future doesn't scare me at all Nothing's like me before Oh,
yeah The song is so hard Oh my gosh, it's always a gamble of
whether I'm gonna hit those notes or not Seish!
You crushed it!
Thank you!
Little wonders.
Oh, I don't wait.
Marino!
Thank you for the pink.
Your beautiful singing always brings the tears to my eyes.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
This song is hard to sing, though.
Holy cow.
Wait, Utau!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Holy!
Disney Princess Minto!
What other Disney?
Could I sing?
I know one that I want to sing.
Um...
Hold on.
I love singing this one when I was just a wee little wisp I
loved singing this one we'll have Prince Philip though his
line and I'll do I'll do Princess Aurora's line
I know you I've walked with you once upon a dream I know
you, the gleam in your eyes is so familiar a gleam.
Yet I know it's true that visions are seldom all they seem.
But if I know you, I'll know what you'll do.
You'll love me at once, the way that you did once upon us.
But if I know you, I know what you'll do, you'll love me at
once, the way you did once upon a dream.
Oh my, I'm not supposed to talk to strangers.
Tell me your name.
Minky.
Uh, I'm Philip.
Oh, it's so nice to meet you.
Philip.
Has anybody named Philip anymore?
I know you.
I worked with you once upon a dream.
You did?
I know you.
Who is this guy?
And I know it's true That visions are seldom all they seem
But if I know you, I know what you'll do You'll love me at
once The way you did once
upon a dream
get prince philip out of here get get out of here i'm
dancing with the animals get out of here mister get out of
here get out of that god your uncle's name is philip philip
god knows probably can do that one I wonder if they have it
on here when did you find out that you're literally the
Disney princess and the cutest girl in the world I'm not a
princess maybe no I'm a maid a maids can't be a Disney
princess I'm the I'm the maid that's locked I'm the
Cinderella that never became a princess never left the house
I am but a humble maid knows
I don't know how I I don't know Hi!
When do you go?
Now, right?
Ah!
Ja!
I'm gonna go!
Finally!
Ja!
I'm gonna go!
Hi!
Mi-hi-o!
Sorry, I can't do anything I can't do anything Soya, soya,
soya, soya Italymy, soya I can't see each other's Mi-hi-o!
Hi!
you won't be able to forgive me.
I'm looking for the way to live in a way, I'm looking at
you.
I'm looking at you, I'm the lonely way.
I'm going to see you, how much it's like in the dark, in the
dark of the dark.
I'm sure you're going to be I was wrong again.
Hi, Hi, Jinzo, Sayi, Ama, Shinzo.
Hi, Shinto.
It's so hot and hot.
On a dream.
Ah, Gengitsu.
Tokash and samayou.
Ah, it's a.
It's a good feeling.
There are no reasons for having you.
I'm so sorry I was doing lines up I'm so sorry I was doing
lines up I can't believe my wish, I want to know, my wish
can't be but everything is God knows.
If you're not the guy, the guy, the guy, the guy, the guy,
the guy, the guy, the other other person, he's gone.
I don't know why?
My beauty is a kiss and dazzle so I I'm gonna go in the dark
in the dark In the long term, I'm sure you're beautiful.
You're a part of my life.
I'm a weak man.
I'm a weak.
God bless me.
My way.
I'm going to give you a blessing.
God bless.
Oh, oh, oh!
Yay!
That was going noise!
Oh!
I actually have a cover of this next song.
But since it's almost summer, my origin story!
What is that supposed to mean?
Since it's almost summer, I want to sing this song too.
Let's see.
Dota Dota
Dota Dota The day Dota Dota Dota The Dota Dota Tama ne'a
good I said
it, and I laughed I was on a dark, light, light, light, I
was like a wakam like you, haphazardly, I walked like a
wakon, the lonely and un-feasants I was forced to be to be
able to see the night in the dark, I looked at the night sky
and I looked at the night sky a star from when are that
please don't don't my my
This is my dream.
Arrega de Nebu, Artael Bega, You are your big thumbs, your
big thine, Remember, you look at the sky.
I finally found you, the ori-hime-sama.
But where is the hikoboshi-sama?
This is a lonely body A funnily one of you, I can't say
anything I can't say anything But I'm always I never knew
about you.
I never knew you.
I never knew you were there.
It's not.
I'm not gonna cry,
I'm sorry, I'm scared.
I'm a
young girl, I'm a little bit, I'm not interested in you.
I'm gonna try the mix.
I think I'm a dreamer.
I'm a strong, strong, strong, loving me.
I'm love you.
I never let you out.
You never!
In the moment, my negative is negative.
I love you, I'm always looking at you.
I have more than that.
I can't tell you, I can't tell.
The moment I want to read this.
I love your heart.
I love you guys.
Look at me, the heart's voice will hear You're the one who's
next to you And the truth is sad-cooked I didn't say it, I
didn't say it I'm sure.
I'm there even enough to remember the moment.
I'm so serious,
I'm really happy to hear it.
I'm building up my own hidden parts of my own secret I'm
here for the night of my long memories I'm here for the last
time to dance
Thank you.
I'm Rice now.
Woohoo.
Alex, thank you so much for the thank you third.
Thank you for singing this, Minta.
One of my favorite anime songs from my favorite anime.
Watanabe, thank you.
So good.
Big Pachi.
Thank you.
Any songs from...
From...
Oh, yeah.
I almost like Gurenge.
Lisa, I think you can nail Gurenge.
I think there's a...
Only one?
Well, not...
Hold on, let's see.
Ugh.
I don't know entirely good and good, though.
I don't know.
I know Homura.
I think?
I think I remember.
It's been a long time since I've sung it.
Wait, let me try.
Homura.
Let's try.
Shiny days are way, way, way, way to celebrate Asaka
announcement.
We could do!
Thank you for playing one of my favorite Japanese songs.
You are...
I said, thank you!
I said, kyo-nist, welcome back.
Thank you!
Wait, now I kind of want to sing...
Wait.
Hold on.
I wonder if they have this song.
I once sung this live at a decently large stage in Japan.
Not so large.
Don't think so much, but...
Uh...
What's it called?
Oh, I know.
Wait, I wonder if I... I wonder if they have it on here.
Wait, uh...
No,
no, no, wait, uh...
I can't remember the name, hold on.
Oh, ah!
I found it.
I found it, I found it.
Oh, I found it, I found it.
Wait, maybe, let me see, karaoke.
Oh!
It's crazy because like singing key songs, songs from like
key anime, like finding karaoke's of them, it's kind of
difficult.
I'm hoping that this does not like get my video taken down.
But we'll see, we'll see, we'll see.
Golden Brown by the Stranglers.
I don't think so, but thank you for the Super Chat.
Minto daiski!
Te Amo!
We'll see though.
it.
This is
from Konada After Story, Tokyo Kizamura.
This is from Konada After Story, Tokyo Kizamura.
you.
I've just cut it down, and I'll be able to enter it.
I'll be able to enter it.
When you and me just went through the side of the mountain,
the warm, warm, warm, warm, warm, I'm here, here, here, I'm
looking back at you.
You only, you only I loved you.
I said, I said, my eyes and my eyes get far
far far always always always one, one, but I'll show you
I'll show you I'm so happy to keep you.
I'm always, always, always, always keep you.
The cold, cold, hot, cold, hot, hot, hot, hot, three-northy
of the you're there to stand there me you you you only you
are you you were
you were
so looked I
love you.
You only, you only, you love me.
You love me.
You only, you only, to to that we we that that time one that
that I don't
know The one, two, punch is
good.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I love singing that song, Tokyo Kizamu-Uta, from Klanada.
Oh, well, I said Klanada, but it's Klanada after story,
right?
So, yay.
Pachi, pachi.
Oh,
I did say after story.
Oh, just kidding.
kidding.
Should we sing another key song?
Yeah.
Maybe.
Resolution by mind the eye.
That's zero animal.
I don't think I know it.
I'll look into it.
Thank you.
I'm so tired, I'm bored, I'm old, I'm tired, I'm tired, I'm
not anymore in that I'm always wanted to be, I couldn't say
anything, I'm sad, I'm sad, I'm sorry, I'm
My friends are the summer's road A long, thick wind and a
good wind Suresh, I'll say, A long, long, A long, A long, A
long day A long hand in my To be the hope
Kiehuehue hikoki gumo OIKKEKETE, OIIHIKET KIEH KIEH KIEH
KIEH KIEKH This ocavoh koi'er That day from that day, It's
always Right, straight, We're all right, We're all right,
We're all right, We're all right,
Sing it all the summer classics this time.
Singing all the summer classics this time.
The honey-touching are always the same dream.
I always look at the same thing.
I look at the same place I always look at.
I have a dream and a dream.
I look back at my eyes.
Oh, oh, you don't know You don't know You can change the way
We'll remember And please, please Please, please please
Please, don't know why we're driving.
Ah!
Oh, yeah, oh, oh, oh Oh, yeah!!
Fasting through Aids Two people are Laing out It's all about
The straight line M'nezzasins are there .
The airsets are Oh, it's so good The The Echolking Gumo We
were looking Looked at It was so bright It was so
It's always It's always It's always It's always Oh, my god.
I'm so happy to let you know.
Missouzoo!
Such a good song.
Yeah.
so good such a good song I don't think I've ever sung it
before no I think about it what's another key song or we
could just keep hitting the the feels maybe another key
angel beats angel beats hold on uh wait do I do do do I
don't wait I know I remember crow song more than I remember
my solier beats If only I remember Ichiban no Because that's
technically Elisa song Hold on, wait I'm gonna try this
Find a way, from here to here, from here.
Found out, find out.
I find a logo Canadero Canadero Talk Missoula Missoula I
can't see I can't see In the city The star is the The star
is the The crass and the The crass and the chathons I'm glad
to cry.
I'm always thinking, when I'm sleeping, when I'm sleeping,
find a way, find a way, I'm singing a song I'm gonna sing,
I'm gonna sing, rock on, rock on, hear it, rock on, I'll
sing, I know.
I'm always fond of the color.
So you know that's a good thing I feel like if I say
anything, if you say it, I'm sorry.
It's the black on the hallowed, let it, it's gone,
it's all right.
The dark is dark, the moon is already falling.
I want to be able to hear you.
But hey, I'll do it.
Tonight's a big night story.
Find a way from here.
From here.
Found out.
Find out.
Rock on.
Canadero.
I don't feel like that song
suits my voice but that's the only one I remember so well
it's the only one I remember as well as because I feel like
I listen to it the most it's such a it was such a strong
start to the to the show wasn't it like episode one that
they did that song and you're like oh angel bees hmm
beautiful thank you let me try Let me try Homura.
If I can remember it.
I think I can.
Thank you.
I thought it was a long time ago, I thought it was a long
time ago.
The light is still in my heart, and it's still in my heart.
We're going to say, I'm gonna start to fight you in the
future.
I'm going to say, I'm in love for love.
The dream's one way to come out.
I'm going to love you.
I'm going to be strong.
I'm going to say, I'm going to say, I love you.
Natsukashi, On a long way
To get trapped
in a Zangoku na'kaka Naki-sacen-dye As you grow up, the more
you grow up to grow up.
And I don't want to lose you.
I'm not going to lose you.
If you fall down, you will feel the pain.
But I'm not going to feel the pain.
Your words, your wishes, I'm going to be able to protect
you.
I'm going to
hold you to the heart.
I feel like I don't remember this song at all.
I feel like I'm winging it.
The play in the hands of men.
Hockey-tombers, the hard, lighted in the light.
The light shines on you, the sky is for the future.
The light is always the happiness and the promise and the
promises are gone.
The way to go, to go ahead and move back to the future.
The way they look
I don't
remember that song at all.
I was like, you know.
My goodness.
Yay!
Yippee!
Can you sing Magia?
By myself?
Like, uh, like...
But that's like a...
That's like a group song.
Kotoko!
What?
I always sing a shooting star because I love that song so
much but I feel like I should sing something else
agony I can't ever remember it is that it's gonna meet that
I always get both a Kanazuki Namiko song Wait, no, wait,
risa blip wait.
Oh, yeah, wait, wait, let me add that to the list.
Why?
Yeah, why, yeah, why?
Yeah, someone asked.
Oh, agony.
Hold on, let me hear it.
Let me hear it real quick.
If it's the one that I'm thinking of.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do.
It's kind.
I love Kanazuki no Miko.
Yeah!
I can't read it.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I can't read.
Hold on.
Okay, now for real, for real, for real.
For real.
I can't read.
That's...
It's got...
Oh, so, just kidding.
I'm early.
Wait, am I early?
No!
No, I wasn't early.
Oh my gosh, I'm stupid.
I'm so stupid.
Okay, one more time.
Third time's a charm.
Ha ha ha ha.
I never saw a dream, but it's not true.
I just remember the night of light, I'm surrounded by the
way, I'm going to look at the dark, and my eyes are not so
much.
I'm sorry, at least just now.
It's not going to be like the night and the night winds are
just in the dark.
The night's dark and the dark are flowing over the dark.
What I want?
My eyes are in the dark.
I want to know the dark.
It's all time, it's been like a million years since I heard
this song.
You guys know Kanazuki no Mi-ko?
The way we're on the way we're all going to be All together
and say-a-narrant It'll be a new-kizuna And it'll be so By
the way we are just being The same world we're all going to
be in the same world Reminds me of the sadness We're all
going to be able to see
It's such a bizarre show.
Oh my gosh, it was so strange.
But the music in it is Chef's Kiss.
All like a full Kotoko soundtrack.
100% recommend for the soundtrack.
I have the box set still.
I was looking at it the other day and I was like, Ah,
Kanazuki no Miko.
It's like underneath my table.
At this very moment.
Yuri plus Mecha is like chocolate and peanut butter.
I know!
Someone to watch over.
me Ella Fitzgerald oh wait you totally own the song no wait
check it out sometime I'll I like Ella Fitzgerald so it's
someone to maybe I do maybe I tried to learn it for the jazz
show I can't remember thank you so much our night terror
thank you thank you
um let me try let me find a way a way a wall
so good you know it won't sound so good
um because it's like a karaoke version you know so listen to
the original by asaka asaka was announced as my guest for
legends anew the the um the uh denser 2 3d live happening in
july so um yeah i'm excited Yaya, Yaya, Yaya, Yaya, Yaya,
Yaya, Yaya, okay.
Yes, this one, okay.
My eyes are open, my eyes are open I started to look like a
little bit like that I'm kind of wakashy and I'm alone, I
get to go go With all the words, all the words, the nothing
that's not a thing, I don't know, I don't know it, I'm
nervous, I'm nervous about it But, today, from the morning
to the night
Just like I'm a boy Why are you a boy?
Do you think that there's going to be some love?
This love, this love My big hug, I'll stop it P-P-P-P-P-M-Y
P-P-P-P-P-P-M-Y-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P- This is love,
love, love
This is just my love I'm just I'm just I'm just a little bit
of a little bit of a lot of love
Chica chak-chate more!
WIRE-WIRE CIME-TICKER-WIRE WIRE-WIRE This, this pain is
What's the pain?
Like Fully-tum-tum-tum-tum-tum You know, You know, I'm a
wadda-sust, I'm stash-cum-tum-tum ...
...
Why?
Goal, Risky, what?
...
Gwen,
It's such a fun song.
It's like my favorite Asaka song maybe.
I used to, well actually I love so many of her songs.
But this one probably is my favorite now.
Two wolves and Saiminto are.
fighting for the mic so if you like that song you should
come to uh legends and new or or watch legends and new i
guess if you are already coming oh then you should come too
and also um uh uh Oh
And maybe you should learn the why you why you for no
particular reason Be ready be ready maybe next time you hear
that song to also go at the same time you know maybe no
particular reason
maybe learn i'm doing i can't see my arms are up but i'm
doing the why yeah why you the movement next time i do a 3d
karaoke i will i will i will show you She's
getting...
...et backed by the head of the blue's blackheads in her
life She's at the voulez'n no future Now, underneath her
debtor From the okay place to understand That's all, if
you're a little more than one, There's no one, but you're
alone I'll be back to you.
I'll be back to you.
I'll never be back to you.
I'll be the key holder.
The night's gone, I'll be the one with my white-haired, the
girl's a little bit sad.
I'm so tired of feeling so tired.
Show the ring Tum Tum Tum Tum
The bondage starts to abode Starts to get the chime The next
year, the start To get the chimes To get the love It was me
It's so It's only me It's so It's your pain To get the help
you
In the room, the room is a blue sky.
You're my friend.
So, you're my friend.
I'm my friend.
So, if you're not where you're at, there's no place to be.
There's no place to live in a world and love each other I'll
repeat it again Flashback, semi-no-core Never will be back,
I'll never be back Toe, I'll be the key holder The night's
gone, the white-haired, the white-haired-natured
I'm so sad.
SASHITEDTA Ah BING
BONG BING BONG BING BONG BONG
It's so sad It's a lie, right?
Mmm, it's a The lyrics are so sad for this song.
But the song is so upbeat, but the song is so sad.
Yay!
A lot of summer songs today.
I'm just in the, I'm in a summer mood.
Oh, I thought that said eat peanut butter.
I thought the notification said eat peanut butter.
Crying in the clone.
I'll sing another sad song.
Sad song time.
Wait, actually, let me check this one real quick.
Yeah.
Sad song, sad song.
But you're the one who's the best for you to go ahead and go
ahead and go ahead.
I'm looking at you.
The final day, you're going to ride, I'm going to leave you.
I'm going to run, slowly and the ground is going to go.
Don't cry, don't cry, but I really want to see you.
Don't go ahead.
Far away, far away, far away, far away Leave me, leave me,
I'm not quite able to see you The night goes away Don't cry,
don't cry, But I really want to say it all Don't say it,
Don't say it I'm always
the same It's a gloom that I always thought But you're more
than always, you look like me, and I look at you and I look
at you Time just goes to go and take me to take me on the
way back to the dark but I'm not alone, is it okay?
The lighters are lighted and a shadow is making me alone,
it's a long way to get away
I'm here.
I'm streaming literally right now.
Look at the flutes!
Oh, so!
Boop, Snowy!
Thank you so much for the aquasuba.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you so much.
I really, really, really appreciate it.
Appreciate it.
I did a cover of this song.
Actually, did anyone watch that?
Wait, hold on.
Wait, wait.
Works been rough, but your streams always cheers me out.
Cheers me out.
But you sing stars by Benson Boone.
Wait.
I don't...
Wait, I only know when Benson Boone song.
Wait.
It's...
It's, uh...
Ow.
Uh...
Oh.
What's a...
Wait, hold on, I'm looking it up.
Benson Bruh and...
He had a cookie named after it.
Right?
Am I crazy?
Didn't he have a cookie?
A cookie.
The cookie!
Moonbeam ice cream!
Beep-bobby-bobby-bob...
Wait, yes, that one!
The Moonbeam ice cream cookie!
That crumble cookie.
That's the only thing I know about that guy.
Moonbeam ice cream.
I have a cookie.
I'm a dog cookie.
This is my cookie.
Moonbeam ice cream.
I made this cookie.
I don't know what the song is called.
Is it called the moonbeam ice cream?
sorry i don't really know so much about that guy um i did a
i did this song um but it was a remix it was a version it
was a remix of snake eater and also bakamitai but i will be
singing the bakamitai version actually i have to pee let me
let me go party real quick listen to this
I'll be right back.
Actually, what if I just put on the snake-eater Baka Mekai
while I go to the bathroom?
You can listen to that instead.
It's called Serpent Eater.
And this is me.
This is me.
Oh, shoot.
It's only two.
Okay, I'm gonna loop it.
It's only two, three minutes.
Okay, I'll be right back.
I love you all the way to the world Even though the truth is
a little bit I can't see you I can't smile, I love you all I
don't want to be a bad With her lips and her lips are really
Kibuki, you.
But, but, why did you say Sayonara was said Dame,
Dame, Dame,
I'm Dame Dame me how how remember
I I'm alone
three years even the city changed
I'm Yes,
my name is Minky Yes, my name is Minky Yes, I want a cookie.
Yeah, you should go listen to Serpent Eater.
Yeah!
Absolute cinema.
I'll do a few more songs.
Just a few more.
Baka Me Tai Snow Halation Mix.
Yeah, I know!
There was a whole Baka Me Tai remix album that they made.
Yes, yes.
Let's see.
What do I want to sing?
Can I sing this song right now?
Let's see.
Let me, I think I'm going to go back to some English songs,
probably.
But we'll start with this one.
Still singing sad songs.
Sorry.
I never had that many friends growing up, so I learned to be
okay with it.
Just me, just me, just me, just me And I'll be fine on the
outside
I like to eat in school by myself anyway So I'll just stay
right here, right here
I'll be fine on the outside So I just sit in my room after
hours at the moon And think of who knows my name You cry if
I died, would you remember my face?
Oh, I left home, I packed up and I moved far away.
Last one day, and I laughed, I laughed, I laughed.
I sound fine on the out.
Sometimes
I feel lost, sometimes I'm confused, sometimes I find that I
am not alright And I cry, and I cry, and I cry
Just sit in my room after hours with the moon And think of
who knows my name Would you cry if I died?
Would you remember my face?
Yay, that was fun on the outside Thank you.
Thank you.
Let's see.
I want
to try this song.
It's not quite a Disney song.
But do you guys know this song?
Do you guys remember Anastasia, the movie?
Even though it's not accurate at all, I still love it so
much.
Heart don't fail Who are you?
Sorry, let me restart
Heart don't fail me now Courage, sorry Desert me, don't turn
back Now that we're here People always say Life is full of
choices No one ever mentions Or how the world can seem so
vast On a journey to the past
Somewhere down this road I know someone's waiting years of
dreams Arms will open wide I'll be safe and wanted finally
home Where I belong Well, starting now I'm learning fast On
this journey To the past
This swallowed my spit wrong.
Home, love, family.
There was once a time I must have had them too.
I will never be complete until I find you.
One step at a time.
One hope, then another who knows where this road may go Back
to who I was, on to find my future things My heart still
need to know Yes, let this be a sign, let this road be mine
Let it lead me to my past me home at last I can't hold it
yes asked asked that's what I said asked asked
um Let's see.
Pretty good.
AST!
What's upon a December next?
But I...
I want to do...
Not Anastasia.
I'm sorry.
Next time I sing it, though.
I'll sing it next time.
AST.
Wait,
I think I know what I want to sing.
Wait, hold on.
I have to hear it real quick.
Is it this guy?
Hold on.
No.
Oh, what's it called?
Wait, hold on.
Okay, super like, when is this from?
oh my gosh hold on how old is this this is an old song i
think
it came out in the 80s oh my goodness
hold on let me listen to it real quick oh yeah oh
wait wait do i remember this actually wait oh wait i'll try
whatever who cares karaoke.
I don't care anymore.
I'm going to sing with the guy, though.
I'll sing with him, so just in case I mess up.
This song is such a vibe, though.
So good.
Oh, shoot.
You can't hear it.
I just realized.
Let me start it over.
You guys know this song.
Everybody knows this song.
It was not far down to paradise.
At least it's not for me.
When the wind is right, you can sail away and find
tranquility.
All the canvas can do miracles.
Just you wait and see.
Believe me.
It's not far to never land.
No reason to pretend.
And if the wind is right, I can find the joy of innocence
again Oh, the canvas can do miracles Just you wait and see
Believe me
Sailing takes me away To where I've always heard it could be
Just a dream A wind to carry me, soon I will be free.
Fantasy, it gets the best of me.
When I'm sailing,
up in reverie, every word is a symphony.
Would you believe me?
Failing takes me away to where I've always heard it could
be.
Just a dream, a wind to carry me.
Soon I will be free.
This song has such like dad vibes.
Just like dad driving vibes.
But it's not far back to sanity At least it's not for me And
if the wind is right you can sail away And find serenity Oh
the canvas can do miracles Just you wait and see Can you
believe me?
Takes me away to where I've always heard it could be Just a
dream, the wind to carry me Soon I will be free
Yacht rock?
Yeah!
I've always wanted to try singing that song on karaoke.
Wait, that reminds me of another one I want to sing.
I think.
I want to sing this one too.
Wait, where is it?
This one.
I think?
Let me double check.
It's so good.
It's such like a vibe.
It's such a vibe.
Oh, wait.
Maybe this one?
I think so.
Okay.
This one too!
I want to sing!
Come a little bit closer Hear what I have to say
Just like children we sleeping We could dream this night
away
But there's a full moon rising
in the light
We know where the music's playing Let's go out and feel the
light Because
I'm still in love with you I wanna see you dance again
Because I'm still in love with you harvest moon
we were strangers I watched you from afar I
loved you with all my heart
but now it's getting late and the moon is climbing high
I want to celebrate See it shining in your life
Because I'm still in love with you I want to see you dance
again Because I'm still in love with you On this harvest
moon Because I'm still in love with you I wanna see you
dance again Because I'm still in love with you On this
harvest moon
I got close Sorry What happened?
Let's do one last song One last song I think I know what I
wanna sing too I always sing this song, but I like this song
so much!
So I don't care, I'm gonna sing it again!
You can dance, you can dive, having the time of your life.
Ooh, see that girl, watch that scene, dig in the dancing
queen.
Thanks for letting me do karaoke today, you guys.
I really appreciate it.
Friday night and the lights are low.
Looking out for a place to go.
Where they play the right music.
Getting in the swing.
You've come to look for a king.
Anybody could be that guy.
as young and the music's high.
With a bit of rock music, everything is fine.
You're in the mood for a dance.
And when you get the chance, you are the dancing queen,
young and sweet, forever 19.
Feel the beat from the tambourine Oh yeah You can dance You
can drive Oh
see that girl Watch that scene Digging the dancing queen Pop
pop You're a teaser, you turn him on Leave him burning and
then And you're gone Looking out for another Anybody will do
You're in the mood for a dance And when you get the chance
You are the dancing queen Young and sweet Forever 19 Dancing
queen Feel the beat from the tambourine Oh yeah, you can
dance
Oh, see that girl Watch that scene Sticking the dancing
queen
Sticking the dancing queen
Sticking the dancing queen Bye
bye, bye, bye, bye, bye Bye, bye Bye bye bye bye bye The the
the Bye Sorry it was
a bit of a shorter stream I've been fun Lizard, lizard,
lizard Lizard,
lizard Bye bye sorry for the change of schedule From my
stream schedule